our main story tonight concerns
something Americans simply can't get
enough of prison we we love to be
entertained by it from orange is the new
black
to seemingly MSNBC's entire weekend
programming to the TNT classic Tim
Robbins stand shirtless in the rain the
movie we love prison so much a shocking
number of Americans are currently inside
one as we learned last week during a
House Judiciary Committee hearing our
nation now has the greatest number of
prisoners of any country in the world
nearly one in every 100 adults in
America is in prison or jail that's true
we have over two million people behind
bars right now we have more prisoners at
the moment than China than China we
don't have more of anything than China
other than of course debt to China and
it didn't it didn't always used to be
this way our prison population has
expanded Eightfold since 1970 the only
other thing that's grown at that rate
since the 70s is varieties of Cheerios
cue fruity Cheerios your trumped-up
Froot Loops and you know it and look
look our prison population has exploded
for a number of reasons from the
dismantling of our mental health system
to mandatory minimum sentence laws which
help explain why 97% of people plead
guilty to federal crimes rather than
risk going to trial to of course
drugs because half the people in federal
prison are there on drug charges and it
accounts for a quarter of admissions to
state prisons and of course it's tricky
to know how to feel about all this
because on the one hand the war on drugs
has completely solved our nation's drug
problem so that's good but on the other
hand our drug laws do seem to be a
little draconian and a lot racist
because while white people and African
Americans use drugs about the same
amount a study has found that African
Americans have been sent to prison for
drug offenses at up to 10 times the rate
for some utterly known reason it
to me it reminds me of a joke you know
black people who commit drug offenses
they go to jail like this whereas white
people don't go to jail at all okay so
many people so many people are
incarcerated in America right now it's
become one of the things that Sesame
Street has to explain to children my
dad's my dad's in jail when I was about
your age my dad was incarcerated too
incarcerated is when someone breaks the
law a grown-up rule and then they have
to go to jail or prison
just think about that we now need
adorable singing puppets to explain
prison to children in the same way they
explain the number-7 or what the moon is
and at least Sesame Street is actually
talking about prison the rest of us are
much happier completely ignoring it
perhaps because it's so easy not to care
about prisoners they are by definition
convicted criminals in fact it's so easy
not to care that we are really
comfortable making jokes about one of
the most horrifying things that can
potentially happen to them go directly
to jail do not pass go do not collect
$200 and do not I repeat do not drop the
soap
look doubloons don't drop em you know
what if we were in prison you guys if
you like my we're going to
federal pound-me-in-the-ass prison what
you got any idea what they do to eggs in
San Ricardo prison it ain't over easy oh
do you get it you get it the egg is
gonna get against its will that's why
it's funny
look wake up your children and explain
that joke to them they'll love it go we
are somehow collectively able to laugh
about references to the fact that 4% of
prisoners reported being sexually
victimized in the past year one in 25
now that might not sound like a lot but
think of it like this if every time you
bought two dozen donuts one of them had
been raped
you'd be pretty upset and those are
pastries prisoners are people if you if
you don't know a prisoner or think that
you're ever likely to become one then
their safety and healthy is not going to
be high on your list of priorities you
don't need to know anything about the
conditions that they live in but you
know who should know but maybe the
director of federal prisons and yet
watch him almost comically struggle to
recall a basic detail about one of the
most mentally excruciating things
prisoners can be subjected to solitary
confinement
how big is a cell how big is the average
cell in solitary say that the average
sized cell yeah the size of the cell how
big is it what is I'm trying to get this
is a human thing we're talking about
we've got a lot of statistics how big is
the cell the average size of a cell is I
guess I'm 25 you're looking for the
space of what the yes
the dimensions in feet and inches the
size of the cell that a person is kept
in I want to get some idea of I don't
know
am I asking this wrong no you're not you
are not asking it wrong as far as I can
remember you're just asking what the
style of the cell is but but it
was a long time ago and and to be fair
he did eventually get an answer the
average size should be equivalent to
which six by four what six by four a
couple of things there one that was
clearly a guess and two six by four is
barely an elevator that that is the
length of a six-foot party sub
by the length of the amount of that
party sub that's left over the following
day cuz nobody wants party sucks
look people put their hands all over
them they're disgusted know what that's
not the point that's not the point
but thankfully a few minutes later the
record was corrected for don't you
actual is ten by seven for the cell size
Oh ten by seven step this way your
highness plenty of room for a ping-pong
table and an imaginary opponent as your
mind slowly becomes untethered what is
clear so far is that we are doing a
terrible job of taking care of people
that it is very easy for all of us not
to care about but here's the thing
increasingly we aren't taking care of
them at all private subcontractors have
steadily been taking over certain
services like the aramark
corporation who provide food to prisons
and a promise that with Aramark you can
expect more more savings and hey look
when you're being thrifty with food
costs what's the worst that can happen
record shows 65 instances where aramark
employees failed to provide food or ran
out the private
Aramark changed recipes to include
cheaper sometimes substandard
ingredients Aramark correctional
services made headlines recently after
maggots were found in food served at
prisons here in michigan that is not
good the only time when you are happy to
hear the words maggots were found is
when you are a maggot whose family was
lost at sea we floated three days on a
piece of bread but we never lost hope
and it's not just food being privatized
it's prison healthcare to Arizona tried
that guess how it turned out medical
spending in prisons dropped by thirty
million dollars and staffing levels
plummeted 50 people died an Arizona
Department of Corrections custody in
just the first eight months of this year
compare that to 37 deaths in the
previous two years combined 50 deaths at
this point you could hire the people who
pretend to be doctors on Grey's Anatomy
and you would probably have a lower
mortality rate and a lot more intrigue
cutting costs has led to some incredible
things happening in Arizona one prisoner
had a c-section in jail and this is how
she says they treated her they decided
to use sugar kitchen sugar what do you
mean they use kitchen sugar um the
packets like McDonald's the sugar they
would open it pour it inside and put
gauze over it and tape it up and and had
to do that for like three weeks and they
pour them in your c-section yeah did
they tell you why they were doing that
one of the doctors learned it from I
don't even know I don't know but
basically it's a home remedy sugar was
used to treat wounds before the advent
of antibiotics back in the early
nineteen hundred's yeah but then we all
decided it was no longer an acceptable
medical practice like curing a child's
cough with heroin
well he's not coughing anymore yeah he's
not really doing much of anything
anymore
and I can't find any of the good silver
look
you will never pay a political price for
treating prisoners like this woman badly
you don't even need to pretend to care
here is how one Arizona lawmaker
responded to her story that doesn't
sound like a true allegation that sounds
ridiculous
no prisoners have you know 24/7 to think
up allegations and write letters I'm not
saying that that some of them can't have
a basis in fact but you got to take them
with a grain of salt or in the case of
the hospital maybe a grain of sugar
somewhere in hell Satan just sharpened
his pitchfork and said to his secretary
do me a favor Janis and let me know when
that guy gets here okay I just want to
be ready many states are even
contracting out entire prisons nearly 9%
of prisons are currently run by private
firms like geo group and Corrections
Corporation of America who had combined
revenues of over 3 billion dollars last
year their publicly traded and while
their marketing materials emphasize how
much they do to help their prisoners
rebuild their lives their pitch to
investors has been a little bit
different in a recent investor
presentation CCA pitches its unique
investment opportunity
another reason investing in the jailing
of people makes good financial sense
high recidivism oh but that is a great
way to reassure your investors look look
look we see your concerns you know what
if we fully rehabilitate the prisoners
and they become fully functional members
of society well don't worry that's not
the kind of company we're running here
don't worry once we're done with these
prisoners they're like human boomerangs
they're broken right in the middle and
they keep coming back the key problem
with running prisons as businesses is
that prisons are then run as businesses
pay and staffing ratios are so much
lower than a geo group youth facility in
Mississippi sometimes had just two
officers overseeing as many as 256
prisoners that facility eventually
closed but only after a federal judge
wrote that physical and sexual abuse was
rampant there because its operators had
allowed a cesspool of unconstitutional
and inhuman inhuman
acts and conditions to germinate now I
know that geo will say that presents an
unbalanced picture of their company so
in the interest of balance I will point
out that they've got an award from the
state of Florida citing their bold and
innovative cost-saving business
practices although I think we all know
when the state of Florida gives you an
award that award is basically sarcastic
in fact a quick side note the award was
signed by Florida Governor Rick Scott
who has led the drive for prison
privatization in his state but on one
condition what I've said all along is
that yeah this is not dirty for
detectors this table
I just saved money there's no way we'll
do this we don't say money as you know
Phil says if we don't save at least 7%
we don't do prison privatization hey hey
listen if you think Rick Scott is gonna
look the other way for a company with a
history of the physical abuse of minors
for savings of a mere six percent you
don't know Rick Scott okay Ricky needs
seven Ricky one seven Ricky like seven
okay now if you happen at all to be
interested in asking Rick Scott about
the conduct of the geo group for
goodness sake don't do it tomorrow night
he's busy we actually checked and he's
going to be at a fundraiser at the home
of and this is true the CEO of geo group
I believe the theme of that fundraiser
is a cesspool of unconstitutional and
inhumane acts look
this is this is all so depressing
private prisons are bad yes but the
whole system just seems fundamentally
broken you know what I think if you
don't mind I need a minute I too need
some help understanding this if you
don't mind hey Joe
you seem sad yeah I am sad Timmy it's
just I've been looking at the prison
conditions in America and the whole
system is just so horribly broken yeah I
know what you mean my daddy's in jail
right now for a low-level drug offense
you think that's exactly what I'm
talking about to me that's crazy
well my daddy's in jail because he
killed four people yeah well okay he's
actually a dangerous individual who
needs to be in jail so that's not really
the same thing my dad is in jail and
people pay money to see him yeah that's
actually a zoo that's different
he's in a zoo okay but it looks the same
to him well let's not conflate the two
always gone okay hey hey Dad how barely
broken is the prison system yeah I can't
believe I'm gonna say this but one
prison actually put sugar in a woman's
c-section oh wait a second what's the
c-section oh yeah um oh wait wait what
you mean like the letter C yes yes yes
that's what I'm a he thought that that's
exactly what I mean yeah yeah that's it
make you feel better if we thing about
it
it's that that needs to be spoken
America's prisons are broken it's a hard
truth about incarceration prisons are
needed for a civilization but mandatory
minimums for heroin and crack stack the
system against Hispanics and blacks a
prison population is bigger than
Slovenia cuz we put people in jail
instead of treating gets the funny yeah
I know they put my dad in jail cos they
say is a monster Oh what what what did
he do nothing they just said he looked
like a monster well that's racial
profiling and that's wrong too okay
here's a fact that needs to be spoken
America's prisons are broken prison
conditions are a national disgrace weak
violence Onegin and possibly rain and we
shouldn't lock up reptiles just to look
at their face those are zoos
those are zoos your dad is an alligator
in a zoo I'm a crocodile I'm a crocodile
oh geez you evilest oh we all look alike
right no no that's no website
like no no you can't put that on me that
is clearly not what I was saying
that's so ignorant oh it's a fact that
needs to be spoken America's prisons are
broken is brought to you by decades of
neglect no lack of political Curie a
generous donation by the G oh yes well
as viewers like you